[Music]
although there is evidence of potential
violations of the statutes regarding the
handling of classified information our
judgment is that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring such a case and
that was then FBI director James Comey
announcing back in July of 2016
that the bureau would not recommend
charges for Hillary Clinton now a
bombshell new discovery from two US
senators is casting doubt on whether
Comey was taking the investigation into
Clinton's misconduct seriously in a
letter written to current FBI director
Christopher Rea senators chuck Grassley
and Lindsey Graham alleged that Comey
dropped at a statement clearing Clinton
of all charges quote long before FBI
agents finished their work and quote
according to the senators the state the
statement was drafted before Hillary
Clinton was even interviewed and joining
us now with reaction to these shocking
new revelations from the American Center
for Law and Justice president Trump's
attorney Jay Sekulow and Fox News
contributor former White House press
secretary Ari Fleischer gentlemen this
is a huge story really quite a bombshell
it's one that many people were talking
about during the campaign but now we're
actually seeing the story has some legs
to it
Jay I'll begin with you do you feel that
there is a violation here of the Hatch
Act I think the Hatch Act at a minimum
but I think there's something more
serious and that is the whole
investigation evidently was just a fraud
on the American people was a faux
investigation you've got James Comey now
with emails going back and forth where
he's drafting three months before they
interview 16 witnesses including the
supposed target of the investigation
exoneration basically a declination
letter before they interviewed the
witnesses so you got asked yourself
really what's going on here and and
James Comey had the nerve to testify
under oath that he had to come forward
last July to make his statement because
the whole process where Loretta Lynch
met with President Clinton on the tarmac
in Phoenix cast doubt on the scope and
nature of the investigation in the
integrity of the Department of Justice
and the FBI but Kimberly here's the fact
the fact
evidently he already made up his mind
three months before the investigation
really got underway so this whole thing
was a fraud on the American people it's
really outrageous it's beyond the
conduct unconscionable really it's
interfering with the system of justice
as we know it the investigation was
already predetermined the outcome so
that's why people are outraged and upset
and really keying in on this particular
story tonight I'm going to go to Ari and
ask you you know is there any reasonable
excuse for drafting a statement like
this this early on see if you can come
up with one first of all I have
tremendous respect for the FBI I've
always been one of those people who have
just the deepest thoughts of the
integrity of that institution and this
story has shaken my belief in the
integrity of the institution at least as
it was being led by James Comey because
what we're hearing here is if this is
true that that investigation the most
high-profile important than the FBI was
doing was a sham the only excuse I could
think of and I hope this is true is that
he also had a similar statement if he
was going to bring criminal charges so
perhaps she was being diligent prepared
two different statements but I think if
that was the case the investigators
would have found the documentation for
that as well they only found it for the
exoneration theory you know it's
fascinating such a great point that
would have been the best way for them to
try to exonerate to say wait a second
let's play this down a second because we
actually prepare to in the event of you
know the outcome depending on what it
was but if they don't have the evidence
J to substantiate that and believe me
Comey is always said that he is you know
I'm meticulous about it I take notes I
typed things up wouldn't there be some
kind of record or notation to back that
up of course but there's also something
else here there's testimony before the
Senate committee where the individuals
including the the special Kevlar senior
counsel to James Comey and his chief of
staff where they said this was a leaning
forward document looking to the fact
that we know where this is going right
that there's going to be an exoneration
but Kim you've litigated cases for a
long time where in the world would draft
a document okay
three months before witness interviews
are complete including the subject and
target of the investigation
Cheryl Mills and some of the key
individuals involved 16 or even 17
witnesses not interviewed that's what
I'm saying here this goes to the heart
of a false statement that was made by
James Comey when he went and made that
whole statement in front of national TV
where he lists out the charges of guilt
yeah and then says nevertheless no
prosecutor would would charge it and it
takes one other thing James Comey took
over the role of the Attorney General of
the United States where she didn't
bother to recuse herself after she had
the meeting but it should have been the
Department of Justice making this
decision not James Comey and the fact he
got away with that is inexcusable he did
get away with it right over time and I
think Deputy Attorney General and WD FBI
director Andy McCabe has explained to do
too right
shake your faith in that Bureau it
shakes your faith and everything the
American people have to believe the FBI
when they said they looked into it and
here's what they found when when Comey
came out with that finding against
Hillary I didn't like it but I accepted
it right I accepted it because you have
to accept what law enforcement tells
only where our society breaks down
commis got a lot of explaining to do any
mccabe has explained to do the American
people have a right to hear it and they
need to be held their feet need to be
held to the fire we need to know you're
absolutely right I mean worst case which
means the truth I think you're right
about that because it was already we
thought you know kind of shades of this
being highly problematic when you as you
said he stepped over the bounds in terms
of his role as an investigator the head
of the FBI and then became judge and
jury and said okay I'm going to tell you
that no reasonable prosecutor that is
not your job that already undermines the
credibility of investigation right there
and no reasonable FBI director would
have leaked a conversation he had with
the President of the United States to a
friend of his so they could leak it to
the New York Times that no reasonable
person would do that either
criminality I he needs to hire a good
criminal defense lawyer in my view all
right and we'll see what do you a quick
final comment the Christopher Rea what
should he do about this he should demand
from James Comey to hear what happened
Jim Comey needs to go public and say it
too this is serious it gets to the core
I'm under can we trust the FBI or not we
must trust the FBI if something was done
wrong sir ray needs to out it I think
you're absolutely right and they have to
do that to restore some of the faith and
credibility you know what the hard work
men and women of the FBI the put on the
line every day to serve this country
they deserve better than that all right
thank you so much appreciate it